- [Voiceover] I'm here with Emily,
our biology content fellow,
to talk about PCR,
or Polymerase Chain Reaction,
which you've actually done a lot of.
Why have you done PCR?
- [Voiceover] PCR was kind of the mainstay
of my graduate project,
where I built all sorts
of different recombinant DNA molecules,
and used them to learn
things about plants.
- [Voiceover] And so what
does PCR in particular do?
- [Voiceover] PCR basically
makes you a lot of copies
of a particular fragment of
DNA that you're interested in.
- [Voiceover] And so how does that...
Why would you need to make a lot of copies
of a particular fragment of DNA?
- [Voiceover] So you might want
to be making lots of copies
so that you can clone it into a plasmid,
and then do some other
experiments with it,
that's a big use.
- [Voiceover] So when
we talked about cloning,
and we're talking about sticking
a fragment of DNA inside of a plasmid,
it's not like you're just
sticking one fragment
into one plasmid,
you're doing that with many,
so you need a lot of fragments of DNA.
- [Voiceover] Exactly. That is exactly it.
- [Voiceover] And you might start
with a very small sample of DNA.
Where else would you have to do PCR?
- [Voiceover] PCR is
used a lot in forensics,
it's also used a lot
in medical diagnostics,
so this could actually be your DNA
that was being checked
to see if you have a gene
that would predispose you
to a particular condition,
all sorts of really
practical applications.
- [Voiceover] Because
it's hard to identify
just one fragment of that gene.
So you want to make copies,
or as they say amplify it,
so that you could run it in gels and stuff
and see how all of those molecules,
how big they are or something like that.
- [Voiceover] Exactly,
if you were just looking
in your DNA pulled out of your cell,
that would be a needle in a haystack.
So this is how you can really zoom in
and look at just the
thing you need to see.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
So, you've drawn some diagrams here,
and I actually have never done PCR,
but you have,
so I'm going to tell you how
I understand it happening,
and then you tell me if this makes sense.
So, what you drew over here,
this is double-stranded DNA,
and this could have been from
a sample of someone's hair,
or whatever else,
and let's say we want to replicate
or make many, many copies
of a fragment of this.
So let's say the fragment
that we really care about
is the fragment roughly from there,
to...
There.
This part is what we want
to make multiple copies of.
And so this first step,
denaturation...
I have trouble pronouncing things.
- [Voiceover] It's a weird word.
You have 96 degrees Celsius,
so this is almost at the boiling point.
So it's quite hot,
and that separates the two strands.
- [Voiceover] Precisely.
- [Voiceover] And so
once they're separated,
then you can cool things down,
although this still isn't that cool.
55 degrees Celsius would
be very uncomfortable.
But you would cool it down to this,
and then these primers show up.
And so one thing to remind ourselves is,
this process is happening
inside of a test tube,
or in a big solution,
So you heat it up, the DNA,
the two strands separate,
and do you just have
this primer lying around?
- [Voiceover] So the primer is something
that you've ordered from a company
and you've ordered a lot of it,
so you put in a ton of
primer in your reaction,
so that there's a really good chance
that when you get to this
step here called annealing,
that a primer is going to bind
to many of your pieces of DNA.
- [Voiceover] So if this is our solution,
is this all happening in water?
- [Voiceover] Water with some salts
and stuff floating around, yeah.
- [Voiceover] Okay. So we have
our solution right over here.
You'd put whatever your
initial DNA sample is in there,
and once again it's a very small amount,
you'd put a lot of that primer,
so you'd want to put
that in a lot of surplus,
so let me do that in this magenta color.
You obviously wouldn't
see it in real life,
it would just all dissolve.
- [Voiceover] It would just
look like a drop of liquid.
- [Voiceover] It would look like...
But for visualization,
you'd put a lot of primer,
and so you heat it up,
the DNA strands separate,
and then when you cool it back down,
this primer is going to be specific
to the ends of the region
that you want to copy.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] And so when you order online
or wherever that you
want a certain primer,
you're going to pick the
sequence of that primer
to be specific to the
regions you want to copy.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
That's super important.
- [Voiceover] Okay. And so
when you cool it back down,
the primer attaches,
and then you heat it back up,
not quite to the 96 degrees Celsius,
but to the 72 degrees Celsius,
where you extend those.
And I'm assuming since it's called
Polymerase Chain Reaction,
that this is where the
polymerase is involved.
- [Voiceover] That is exactly
where the polymerase comes in.
- [Voiceover] So the polymerase
is what is actually extending this.
So I'll just draw a polymerase
enzyme right over there,
doing the extending,
and is it any type of polymerase enzyme?
Can I just take the
polymerase from my cells
and throw it in there?
- [Voiceover] So you actually
need a special polymerase,
because you need one that is going
to be pretty heat-resistant,
so as you were mentioning,
even the cool step of this process
is not something that your body
would want to be hanging out in.
So the polymerase is actually from
a really heat-tolerant micro-organism.
- [Voiceover] And what is that?
It's called a taq polymerase?
- [Voiceover] It's thermophilus
aquaticus, I think?
Makes quite a mouthful.
- [Voiceover] And they
found it at heated vents,
this organism that is able to
stand these high temperatures.
But that I guess leads
to another question,
which is why do you have to
heat it up to begin with?
I guess just to separate the two strands?
- [Voiceover] That's
really the key reason.
You just have to get them apart,
you don't have an enzyme to do it
the way you might in a cell,
so heat does the trick.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so I get it.
So this is one step,
I'm getting at least the
polymerase part of the PCR,
where you heat it up,
the strands separate,
then you have all of
this extra primer there.
Because there's so much primer,
the primer is much more likely to bind to,
at least at this part of the sequence,
then for these two strands
to get back together
at this point,
and then you have the polymerase,
the taq polymerase in particular,
and you would have added
that at the beginning,
the taq polymerase,
I guess I'll put it in a yellow color.
So you would also put all
that taq polymerase in there.
And once again, these
things aren't robots,
they don't know exactly
what they need to do,
they just bump into
things in the right way
and react in the right way,
and then you would also have to add
a bunch of nucleotides.
- [Voiceover] Yes, absolutely.
Your reaction is not going to work
if you forget the nucleotides.
- [Voiceover] So, the taq polymerase,
when you heat it back up again
after the primers have been attached,
is going to start adding
all of these nucleotides.
And what, do you just wait
a certain amount of time?
Will it just keep going on forever?
- [Voiceover] It'll keep
going on for a while,
usually you do pick
the length of that step
to match how much time
you expect the polymerase
to need to complete your fragment.
But it kind of will stop.
Either it will fall off or it'll stop
when you go on to the next step.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
this, I get this so far.
So, so far we have after one cycle,
what you've written here,
after one cycle we would have doubled
at least that part of the
sequence that we care about.
Although we might have copied
even beyond that sequence.
So, where does the chain
reaction come into this?
- [Voiceover] So I guess you
can interpret chain reaction
in two ways,
and one is that's sort of
what the polymerase does,
is you know, add things to make a chain,
but there's actually even
more of a chain reaction
to mention here,
and that's that we're actually getting
this kind of exponential process going on.
- [Voiceover] So you do it one cycle,
you get to this situation right here,
you heat it up, the strands separate,
you cool it down, the primers attach,
you heat it up again, the
taq polymerase does its job,
and like all polymerase,
it goes from the 5 prime
to the 3 prime direction,
we talked about that in the application.
- [Voiceover] Precisely.
- [Voiceover] So now you have two strands,
but now, since all of that
stuff is in that solution,
you can heat it up again,
now these two strands can turn into...
Or these two double strands can now
turn into four single strands,
then you can cool it down again.
Now, they get primers attached to them,
and they're still the same primer,
because we still care
about the same sequence.
And so now you go from one to two to four,
and so you keep repeating this.
And so how many times would it be typical
for you to repeat this cycle?
- [Voiceover] So like, 35 might
be a pretty typical number
of cycles to do.
It depends a little what you're doing.
But you're going to do it a lot of times.
- [Voiceover] And so if
you do this 35 times,
I mean each time you're multiplying by 2.
So it would be 2 to the 35th power,
which is well over a billion times,
so how long would that take?
You've done this before.
- [Voiceover] It depends on
the length of your fragment,
but usually like two to three hours.
- [Voiceover] So in two to three hours,
you can start with one fragment,
and get into the billions.
- [Voiceover] If it's perfectly efficient,
which I wish it always were,
but you usually get
quite a few pieces made.
- [Voiceover] And one thing
that I've always wondered
when I first learned about this,
and I'd like to go into a
lab and do this with you,
is okay, I get that you have your primer,
and then the polymerase is
just going to extend it,
like that,
but I was like well, it's going to be...
How does it know where to stop?
And you explained, well,
on that first pass, it might
not know where to stop,
but then when you start
going in the other direction,
it's going to, so over here,
when it goes in the other direction,
it's going to hit a...
It's not going to have
anything else to copy.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] So most of
the billions of molecules
that you produce,
are going to be both ends
kind of a nice clean cut.
- [Voiceover] The vast,
vast majority, exactly.
- [Voiceover] Fascinating.